how good are the the Vikings I mean last
night gives me the confidence to say
that I again I don't put them in the
49ers class but I think they're very
much in the conversation with that next
group down in the NFC I mean I'm not
gonna sit here and just go all if they
played the Saints the Saints are gonna
Massacre them I don't think so no I
think that they could stand toe-to-toe
with the Saints and do I know if I think
they could win that game I don't know
about that but I think they every bit
can beat the Packers and I think they
certainly give it a play here or there
could stand toe-to-toe with the New
Orleans Saints as well what about the
49ers no I think a 49 you didn't listen
to me because I was gonna ask you I
think we're in a class of their own
right now in the NFC at Minnesota if it
was 49ers at Minnesota yeah I still
think it's a tough matchup for them I
think the for San Francisco 49ers are
the most well put together a boundless
football team in the sport right now so
yeah I think they're they're in the
number one king of football I think that
your Minnesota Vikings are somewhere in
that you know 4 to 6 range 3 to 6 range
wherever you may be and I do think
they're for real and they can keep
answering the bell and kind of play them
big in some big moments and again they
didn't like totally crumble in Kansas
City a few weeks either ago they didn't
play their best but I wasn't like oh my
gosh what a bunch of choke artist they
were well and look the Vikings are
chasing the Packers one game behind them
in the NFC North they can forge a tie in
the division week 16 and a split of the
season series now the Vikings have
otherwise lost to the Bears in the
division if we get to division tie
breakers may be conferenced high
breakers common opponents etc it could
get very interesting once it's time yeah
just start going below that first
tiebreaker assuming they do split the
head-to-head series and end up with the
same record but it could be the
difference between the two seed and the
five seed for the Vikings or two or the
Packers or could be the six seed
depending upon what the Seahawks do but
this is not the year you want to be the
you know five or six now and go on the
road and the NSC enough cuz you go to
Dallas or Philly yes or you're gonna
have to go to either New Orleans or
Green Bay right
then follow yes again and then maybe
play San Francisco in the NFC check it's
just gonna it looks to me like yeah you
you want to at least be a home team in
the wild-card let alone we know how
important it is to have that first those
byes are going to be critical and as I
said during the show today there are
five teams that are alive for the bye
week the Vikings the Packers the Saints
the 49ers and the Seahawks two of those
teams are gonna get the byes and right
now who knows how that's all gonna play
out tonight's game is gonna have a lot
to do with it they they got some things
that you know when you look alike
playoff football right as defense and
being able to run the ball you got that
going for you in Minnesota ten straight
runs last night right when they were
down 2120 the first time they fell
behind in the game ten straight runs
culminating in a touchdown Mike Zimmer
said that's the kind of thing that
breaks a defense as well it does it
actually it wears them out and just I
think between the the creativity they
have in the run game and then you know
like we've said a million times just a
little formula they use off in the pass
game and again they did this last night
let's not forget with arguably their
their second best offensive player Adam
Thielen he's not out on the field I mean
that would have been another issue for
the Dallas Cowboys to deal with too so
that was a really big-time win by that
football team and I think the thing more
than anything I just you know not like
I'm totally shocked they won the game
but the fact that they dominated the
line of scrimmage on both sides of the
ball to me I think was more shocking
than anything and with Adam feelings
hamstring flaring up last week the
Vikings have the Broncos at home then
they're by right they should just keep
him shut out until after the buy when
they go to Seattle for their next
primetime test move whether or not they
truly have it'll be change the narrative
GAC when they go back to see how to
remember last year that game in Seattle
the offense could do nothing yeah the
Seahawks defense not as good now this
year it's a better Viking last year
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports